uno de los mayores ataques rusos contra
Ucrania decenas de misiles Fueron
lanzados por parte de Moscú sobre kiev
los bombardeos fueron dirigidos contra
la red eléctrica nueva instalaciones
generadoras fueron dañadas a pesar del
temor por su vida Los residentes en la
capital refugiados en el metro no
rendían su ánimo ante los embates del
kremlin
Mientras tanto quedó sin suministro
eléctrico
no sabemos nada internet está apagado y
no hay conexión no sabemos nada pero la
gente está saliendo nosotros lo
intentaremos también la estrategia de
Moscú está planteada aprovechar el
invierno como arma según denuncia
atacar nuestra infraestructura
energética hacer sufrir a la gente
durante el invierno es un genocidio
contra nuestra nación pero debo admitir
que nuestra moral Es realmente fuerte y
nunca nos rendiremos
lucharemos hasta por cada centímetro de
nuestro territorio bajo el control de
nuestro gobierno y podremos devolverle
una vida normal a nuestra gente
y permitirles vivir en paz y prosperidad
el alcalde de los daños en la ciudad
como colosales al menos 60 de los
proyectiles fueron derribados por las
defensas antiaéreas según el jefe de las
tropas ucranianas